[Musique]
Sentinelle visuelle inaudible taxes
éducation communautaire mise en place d'une petite
zone
Je ne savais pas que Buffett vous saviez qu'il s'incline à propos de
[Musique]
ou peut-être n'a-t-il présenté que la
baise de la famille d'une grande école Michael se sent parce que  Je
ne veux pas rester dans la foi que vous avez
lavé dans votre souvenir de beauté, surtout ce qui
vient même brûler ce serait bien si nous
étions plus âgés et nous n'aurions pas besoin d'en avoir
besoin et ne serait-il pas agréable de vivre
ensemble,
il a mordu les nouvelles de Sammy des
moments heureux ensemble, nous dépensons des choses
Je souhaite que chaque
oh et ce serait bien
nous a conduits à la maison
elle-elle est la personnalité bien que la
magie des puffers vous dites captive pour ruisseler Casa
Tabora non Super mardi elle vit au milieu de
toutes les pertes jetaient l'apnée
ce soir retrait s'il vous plaît cleome
rendez-vous non nous devrions également connaître l'
ensemble des 3043 adversaires non unifiés
alcatraz volatilité de la nourriture  visiter la
critique le plus tard Oliver Mickey désolé
beaucoup prévalence Papa réaliser
que tout est d'accord si d'autres moteurs de calculatrices sont d'
accord et cetera qu'un
feuilleton nous vendons bien elle a parlé de toi
vodka
Latifa pour oublier le jour de demain si je dis
bien que je prévois c'est un plus beau
mon pantalon, je ne suis pas comme toi,
alors la famille John Tobin pense à ça
presque si tu espères toujours que tu es
parce que, à part les émissions de base, évalue PG
devrais-tu voter moelleux hmm si je te montre
[Musique]
[Musique] les
rêves sont les graines  d'action que nous ferions tous
elfe rappelez-vous qu'une
course en solitaire autour du monde lui a déjà
envoyé mon formulaire d'inscription puis-je souligner
qu'il n'a pas de bateau capable d'un tel
voyage nous allons en construire un pour que vous puissiez toujours
fait quelque chose comme ça avant c'est
le but si je peux le faire alors le
gars qui regarde l'horizon peut aussi le faire
ce n'est pas  encre
je devrais en fait te regarder partir
la pression régulière tombe sur l'homme
seul sur un bateau en mer ne montre aucune
pitié là où les leaders 3 000 milles que
si je continue mes chances de survie seraient de
50/50 si je vire  retour Je fais face à un certain
droit
Je ne peux pas continuer
[Musique]
Je suis là et si je leur disais que
ma semaine Dahle Kroger a publié
un discours remarquable que dois-je faire maintenant
Je pensais que je pourrais mieux jouer au jeu
toujours connecté non  peu importe la distance qui
nous sépare demain et chaque jour après mes
enfants auront toujours besoin de leur père
mais j'aurai toujours besoin de mon mari la vie
doit être vécue la question devient que pouvez-
vous faire
Claire mon amie montre
son film au festival alors je suis descendue
avec elle oh pourquoi tu vois je montre mon
film ici aussi
je me sens intuitive c'est une communauté
allez doucement
je te regarde depuis longtemps
toi  ressemble à un artiste est-ce que oui tu
m'as dit que tu es un enseignant je suis un poète pour  o
et je prends des photos aussi avec ça oh si je
prenais une photo de toi tu n'es plus la même
personne
quelle est la différence entre cette
photo et moi eh bien je sais que ce n'est qu'une
photo mais tu as réellement changé maintenant
je peux le sentir
je  pense que c'était ma patronne c'est elle
qui m'a renvoyé bien sûr sa jalousie
pourquoi tu prends des photos parce qu'elles
ne faisaient que changer les choses c'est
de tout revoir très lentement d'accord qui
ici peut vraiment se révéler à la
classe n'importe qui j'irai
[Musique]
ne parlez pas de moi ne classez-vous pas avec
quelqu'un que vous connaissez bien sûr à l'heure
essayez de ne pas vous endormir tout le monde est
-ce que j'entends un accent oh non non que
gagneriez-vous quel âge avez-vous ne
voulez pas vous Greg  'ai 19 ans ouais je viens d'avoir
14 ans Wow joyeux anniversaire
[Applaudissements
] c'est mon film et c'est ma vie pas
bien tu me connais nous tous pareil mais
ouais comment ça se fait que nous Paul comment ils s'efforcent
que nous soyons célèbres
je suppose que nous  n'as-tu pas une
présence malveillante tu es un méchant parfait je
pourrais  je te vois comme Dracula Frankenstein ah
Frankenstein
je suis le héros pourquoi leur donner du travail je
leur donne un salaire comprends cinq millions de
dollars sur ce film Greg je pensais que tu
te moquais de cinq millions de dollars et
ils ne sont pas reconnaissants que personne ne respecte ma
vision
[Musique]
où étaient  tu es né Tommy Greg, ils ne font
pas partie de voir est-ce que tu veux une
question plus facile d'où vient l'
argent hein arrête juste devant la caméra je sais que
c'est devant la caméra comme tu voulais
[Musique]
film pour toi Brad
et nous juste  reprends essaye de perdre
l'accent les regles a la classe un
sample et la chorale et avant avec da
moment teukolsky
[Musique]
vous